Pro Football Hall of Famer and a man who
played in for these big games he is none
other than Jim Kelly good to see you sir
always good see you rich right back at
you
you wanna you said you would wonder
about my glasses yeah these are pretty
cool I like to 200 ah okay but I can see
good like a distance with these on what
do you think look at Jim Kelly my
glasses right there there's some ugly
looking glass whoa I can see way to go
with these I can see yeah
oh why those are cool there you go I'll
have to check those out later on see I
clean I cleaned him Fourier just like
Jerry Jones had somebody clean his
glasses all right man let's get into it
Tom Brady where does he stand for your
vest net no question right no doubt of
all time yeah and the reason I say that
I mean you looked at so many other guys
and I wrote of course I wasn't around
and watched Johnny Unitas but all the
great things said about him and how
great he was right Joe Montana of course
you know my class with John and of
course Dan but you know he does it
you're in a Urata he does it with
different players all the time they're
not all superstars but he makes it that
way and he rarely has a really good
solid running game but you never count
him out and I'll put it this way I would
never ever bet against and that's for
sure mm-hmm and but for some for
somebody that you know got back to the
game as many times as you did just the
fact that you were able to do that just
takes obviously something what do you
think is within him that gets him that
he this is his eighth one of these he
likes it he loves it give anything else
for you have any conversations well yeah
all the time
yeah we text back and forth as a matter
of fact to be honest with you don't tell
it like it is there's a lot of people
out there that don't like them
especially so good Buffalo Bill fans but
I've always seen the side of him where
he always texts me and said hey Jim do
you need anything for your foundation i
tom is okay I sent a couple jerseys to
your house are to you and he sent into
my house and he's been that way forever
no kidding yeah I mean the biggest heart
and one of those guys if probably people
don't know about
but he is right there for my foundation
whether it's Kelly for kids or whether
it's my sons foundation hunter soap
whatever I need sign send it don't send
it to my office send it to my home and I
would and boom within a couple days he'd
send it right back and again he sent me
this year a pair of his game worn shoes
and in boom they're any worse oh but
he's always been there and the thing
about him is in people even my buddies
even Bruce them they thought you know
when a Jag wanted her playing Jags I
don't know I think the Jags might have
my said guys remember the goats on the
other sideline don't ever call him out
but what happens he brings them back so
that seems that never changed so I'm
trying to pick something up here so
Bruce Smith Thurman those guys they're
rooting for Jackson are you saying why
can't say I wasn't you never bet against
him he is such a good dude - yeah and
people ask me this week about you know
Jax I mean Philadelphia or New England
I'm good friends with Tom but family
comes first
Frank crack is the offense coordinator
for the Philadelphia Eagles and was my
backup during my days in in Buffalo he's
been to the Super Bowl many times just
like I was he doesn't have one of those
rings I would like to see Frank Reich
get a ring because he's deserved it he's
done one heck of a job with Carson Wentz
and of course Nick Foles Jim Kelly here
on the Rich Eisen show at Jim Kelly
12:12 on Twitter do you see any of the
KGUN and what's going on right now at
all the time okay that's week in and
week on every single weekend in the NFL
now people use that all the time to know
how to office which we use 24/7 and even
in my sleep I did it
but yeah you see that all the time and I
love it people want to see exciting
office they don't want to see the run
right run left all the time even though
you have to have a running game I was
blessed to have one of the best and
Thurman Thomas I also had two wide
receivers James Lofton non-jury Reed who
were both in the Pro Football Hall of
Fame so I was blessed but people want to
see scoring they wanna see good things
but the thing I could tell you about
even Tom people say how's he doing
forty years well he doesn't have
defensive ends that like back in our day
that when they hit you they buried you
they can follow through with that hit
they can knock you down hit you as hard
he can but when they're following
through and they're putting you on the
astroturf astroturf not field turf which
is soft astroturf that wears on your
body not only your head but your
shoulder your elbows your knees those
things hurt and these guys are getting
protected so much which they should do
nobody wants to see a backup quarterback
I mean next door pretty good job out to
say it's pretty good there but I'm just
talking about overall people want to see
the exciting quarterbacks play weekend
and week odd they don't want to see all
the backup so what they're doing to
protect the quarterbacks and wide
receivers is what they should Jim Kelly
here on the Rich Eisen show your cancer
gameplan comm we'll get to that in a
second what do you think the bills
should do at the quarterback position
Jim I don't know rich you know Tyrod is
such a great athlete he makes things
happen a lot of quarterbacks out there
could never do consistency probably
needs to get a little better at I like
Tyrod I don't know a big question mark
people always bring up is we have to
take a 21st and 22nd pick in the first
round should they give those picks away
trade up and look for a quarterback
coming out in this year's draft
I don't study it that much or really
know about the individuals coming out
you know for me to say that it's tough
because I see what I see what we have
it's good but I don't know if it's what
we need for the long term but I could
never say anything really a lot of bad
things about at IRA so what about some
Pegula dollars in the Kirk Cousins Bank
what do you think about that if they
decide to do to go that route I'd be for
it you know what whatever they decide
and they have some pretty good guys not
Brandon being a new general manager to
get Russ Brandon who does most see the
marketing side but if that's what they
decide to do whatever they decide to I'm
behind but at least it does look
anything can happen
Marv levy is still the last bills coach
to coach for consecutive years for that
team McDermott appears to have
grasp what it needs to be a Western New
York no since Ross got the mentality
he's got that attitude that I think they
need right so let's get to your cancer
game plan calm you're here on behalf of
Merck what what message would you like
to impart your Jim well to make a long
story short cuz I'm so passionate about
it I remember when I teamed up with him
and I also if I even go back a little
further than that when I was diagnosed
with cancer they told me the biopsy came
back positive for squamous cell
carcinoma and I go what is that and
really it's the cancer the upper jaw and
my wife and I had nowhere to turn
we didn't know who to talk to what is
this and when Mark came to me a few
years ago I said where were you three
four years ago when I needed you sir
because this is what you need they get
it they understand so two years ago we
set up your cancer game plan and I just
challenged everybody right now to go to
your cancer game plan comm log on to the
website share it with your social media
and there's nineteen advocacy groups in
there that has to do with the head and
neck cancer different types of can treat
melanoma different things you can have
logon team up with one of them and for
every one you share it with Merck will
donate five dollars and we look to raise
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
dollars for all these cancer groups
because too many people have no clue
where to go what to do who to talk to
we have hopefully a lot of Leary answers
for you and I get it because I was
blessed after I found out what to do
that I had a beautiful wife two
daughters and my brothers were there for
me from start to finish and I'm a very
blessed man so again your Ganser your
cancer gameplan
yep com let's take this phone call
he's been such a good friend of our show
right still Stewart Matt in Oklahoma
he's sitting there in the middle
heartland of the country's the biggest
fan of your is the biggest Buffalo Bill
friend you there you there Matthew yeah
I'm here shouts and talk to his
quarterback here oh man it's awesome
what do you have on your mind Matthew
you're on with Jim Kelly he's just in
traced I've had a lot of physical
problems over these
surgery's in the gym every time I get
that I think well Jim and the bills man
the bills never gave up it's awesome and
he's always gonna be my favorite well
he's right here tell him I know Jim
you're my favorite man I like I have a
thousand things to tell you but I get on
and I'm like I forget everything no it's
it's all good and that's one thing even
hearing from this gentleman on the phone
so many people in the last couple years
after I be cancer
I travel to country that's all I do now
is I speak all over the already United
States and even in Canada to people in
organizations that need somebody to
inspire them to keep fighting to never
give up and I've been through a lot in
my life from you know even don'ting back
my senior year at college up for the
Heisman Trophy no dreams about taking
care of mom and dad and my five brothers
making them proud of me blow my shoulder
told me I'll never play football again -
going up the Super Bowl four years in a
row and not winning and then having a
son born on my birthday Valentine's Day
and then having him diagnosed with a
fatal genetic disease and passing away
and in a Hall of Fame and you know all
the ups and downs in my life but I've
learned that it's your attitude that you
have to never say die attitude to never
ever ever give up and we all go through
tough times in our life for achieving
you and even a lot of people that I know
and I've talked to since I've been here
but the thing is the surround yourself
with good quality people and I live by
this motto make a difference today for
someone who's fighting for their
tomorrow because what we can do for
other people that may not have a bright
future ahead of them may want to give up
week at least get them to keep going and
it's about the care givers it's about
the family making sure they have that
positive add to their go Matthew there
you go bud thanks for calling any flower
rich man you bet you bet that's Matthew
in Oklahoma right there again your
cancer gameplan comm so just to repeat
the football part of our conversation
Tom Brady is an awesome dude he is
always there for you but when it comes
to the AFC Championship game go Jaguars
and that comes to Super Bowl 50 to go
Frank Reich
the AFC's I can't cheer from every and
I've already talked about [ __ ] but you
know what yeah what I love about him he
loves the game you sure he's having fun
why give up even at an age of 40 I mean
play until you can't play anymore
and he's healthy why not you're going
well you should I bless you can play any
high level and God bless you Jim Kelly
always loved having you on this show
anytime as you know anytime I know thank
you ever make yourself available you
always have a home here
right back at you that's at Jim Kelly
12:12 on Twitter Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience